When he became prime minister in 2012,...
...Shinzo Abe was no stranger to the office.
He'd already held the post for a year in 2006...
...during Japan's so-called revolving door premiership period,...
...when factionalism within the ruling party...
...led to a rapid turnover in leaders.
By 2012, that period was over,...
...offering Abe the chance to rule uninterrupted.
"I will increase jobs and incomes and revitalize the countryside," he promised,...
...aiming to transform Japan's stagnating economy...
...with his own brand of "Abenomics."
Eight years on, the results are still disappointingly mixed.
A staunch conservative,...
...he also set about moving away from Japan's traditional pacifist role...
...and become more assertive with his Asian neighbors.
But it was the unseen enemy of COVID-19,...
...the critics say, saw him lacking in assertiveness.
2020 was meant to be the high point of his premiership,...
...hosting the Tokyo Olympics, which he'd successfully won for Japan.
Abe can blame a degree of bad fortune for a tarnished legacy.
But when he leaves office,...
...the fact that he's served longer than any other prime minister...
...might be the one achievement he's most remembered for.